so I just so glass which actually has
very little glass in it
Samuel Jackson gets a and Samuel Jackson
the credit that should be your first
clue they do kind of a reverse Bryan
Cranston and Godzilla thing here he's
mostly just in the last third but the
last third so it's it's not necessarily
miss title but okay so before I tell you
what I think about this give my thoughts
real fast about what I thought of the
films that came before this unbreakable
I like I was kind of a clever idea still
has some of the Shyamalan isms you know
definitely a lot of them but by like I I
thought was an interesting idea I was
interestingly done you know had problems
but whatever split Oh about the same
thing ahead even more shall Milan isms
in it you know SAR the over writing and
stuff like that and try to tackle some
serious stuff I feel like he's not
really able to do very well but but I
thought it was entertaining guy I
thought was fine I thought the surprise
at the end that now everybody knows was
cuz you know you're watching glass it
clearly it's given away um I felt was
kind of clever and kind of cool and then
there's this one this one's getting
really slammed by critics I think like
if 36 percent I'm Ron Tomatoes currently
and how those all right honestly I feel
like any problems people had with this
are probably at the end and I think kind
of like what I said was played it might
be a little polarizing um because some
people might be like with it that that's
the direction it goes there's well III
won't give it away this is a spoiler
free review but some point somebody
behind me just it's just not the
direction they thought it was gonna go
and so I can see some people not liking
that the only thing I can think of is
like okay there's stuff you can point
out that isn't good in this movie of the
typical Shyamalan isms like it is
overwritten and people take a while to
save the thing
that people other people would say very
quickly and there's a lot of exposition
II dialogue and stuff like that but that
wasn't split as well and that was in
unbreakable you know it is in all these
movies that it critics seem to like you
know it's kind of like when critics love
to the first rush hour but not the
second one it's like why it's like the
exact same movie then it's totally fine
so that was kind of my take on this at
the the only major kind of major problem
I had again is kind of in the ending one
of the main characters it kinda has
there's a conclusion to one of the main
characters that I thought was kind of
lame I thought like oh that's not cool
and you know I'll just say it's Bruce
Willis character again I won't give away
what happens but it's one of those
things where if you watch the movies you
kind of go oh really that that's what it
all you know
meets up to like that I thought that was
kind of lame um but everything else
about the movie is pretty much like what
you've seen the trailers it's the three
characters from these movies mr. glass I
think now the green Guardian or the
green guard I think is what Wilson's
character is sort of being called and
then the beasts playing played by James
McAvoy and Samuel Jackson and McAvoy
either kind of like the villains they're
kinda like these comic book villains and
Bruce Willis is canthus comic-book hero
and the idea is that there's something
going on with like stories being written
in comic book form that are being
inspired by true events or saw these
patterns going on that somehow happen
and that they do exist there are kind of
these super people and everyone kind of
has this feeling this nudge and they
write stories about it but they don't
know why and it's it's it's a fun idea I
mean it's silly of course it's silly but
but I thought was kind of a fun idea so
majority of this is mainly just these
three characters in a mental institution
the trailer kind of builds up if there's
big action sequence and stuff like that
and there
there is there some action there's some
horror elements - it's actually a pretty
good mix of like unbreakable and splint
which are kind of different movies you
know ice it was a horror film what is
more kinda like psychological drama and
they much pretty well here I thought and
most of it is that most of it is this
psychiatrist trying to convince them
that this isn't real it's false so it's
kind of 12 monkeys
it's kind of 12 monkeys meets x-men
Meeks Avengers in a sense because it's
like Xavier talking to Nick Fury which
is very surreal and Nick Fury is in the
wheelchair but so it's just a bad joke
it's nothing like Avengers all right
both ideas a lot like 12 monkeys with
like you know this comic book ish ending
with the people using their you know
kind of superpowers and stuff but it's
if you've seen the other films you kind
of know how this works and no one's
gonna be flying nobody's gonna be
shooting lasers out their eyes or
anything like that it's not quite that
kind of universe but it was so it's
mostly the mental institution like I
said CML doesn't do that much uh and it
is slow and there is a lot of that kind
of exposition dialogue there's one point
where you know it's talking to Wilson
son it was great to see again by the way
I didn't look up but that that has to be
the same actor and he does a good job if
it's not the same actor the an amazing
look-alike so that's really cool it's
really cool seeing him again and they'll
say something about like you know I want
to talk about your mother or what she
had to do with this I know that she died
of leukemia this many years ago it's
like it's that kind of dialogue and I
hate that it's the it's almost the as
you know line you know it's just it's
it's that the writing I really hate but
there's there are moments of that it is
annoying but but it's not everywhere um
a lot of the a lot of the interactions a
lot of ways that they talk and stuff
like that particularly with mega voice
mega voice just having a blast he is
having so much fun and
he's a ton of fun and why I tried the
people that work at the hospital are fun
to watch and Will's is fun to watch uh
it's just kind of them interacting off
each other and for a person like me I
like just seeing characters interact off
each other so I thought that was fine
and then you get to kind of the last
third were Sammy Samuel Jackson kind of
makes a he is in the movie you know but
but he's kind of doing the eye twitchin
thing like he's not there kind of thing
but yeah you see the trailers you know
he's gonna play a bigger part it's
called glass you know he's gonna play a
bigger part and so he starts to really
come in more prominently in the last
third and that's great it's great seeing
him do his day I'm Amy these are these
are some actors that in my opinion
really have to try hard to not be
entertaining Bruce Willis James McAvoy
Samuel Jackson II they are just so
insanely entertaining and they are I
love watching them in this movie I love
seeing him get together in their own
distinct style of acting and just kind
of choose scenery off of one another and
they all do well they all do a legit
good job um and and yeah I feel like the
it's all building up to this ending that
like I said I think some people are
either gonna get into it or not and the
big thing I'll just give you a heads up
they're building up that something else
is gonna happen there Billy out that the
climax is gonna be this one thing it's
not and it's kind of like like they're
on their way to this big climax like
that but then getting to that climax is
the climax if that makes any sense it's
kind of like they're gonna go do this
holy crap thing and on the way to the
holy crap thing stuff happens and then
they never get to the holy crap thing so
keep that in mind because you're gonna
be watching this movie like I did going
oh we're never gonna get there are we
you know it's kind of like a fake out
but that's not the the twist of course
there's like a twist in it um always but
it's weird
they put a couple twists in this ending
and if there's one that shows a
connection between two of the characters
and and I really like that and it was
one of those where you could kind of
like hear the people doggins go oh like
that and I like that one that would that
was really cool it was very comic book
II to this so I really really liked that
but then they kind of keep throwing a
few more on top of it and I'm just
watches like where are you going with
this where you going and when it finally
got to the end and where it all kind of
wrapped up I kind of nodded my other one
okay yeah sure my like that's a nice
enough idea have a nice enough theme and
it does tie all the movies together
relatively well like I said I just don't
like what kind of I don't like the
ending of one of these characters of
wills as guarantor I thought that was
kind of I didn't care for that you know
that didn't feel like that was the
proper ending for these three films but
everyone else and everything else that
you know while it is a surprise I feel
like it kind of connects okay um so yeah
it's it's one of those films where it's
got a lot of Shyamalan is but they're
not laughably laughably bad the only
parts I think are laughs whoo laughs
ibly bad is that the police like
anything in terms of like security or
the police or anything like that which I
guess you would kind of expect in a
movie like this is pretty laughably dumb
all the ways the police try to stop
these people especially in the opening
where they have like this flashing light
device that can like stop MacAvoy and
they just they know where he is and they
set it all up and everything it's like
super super high-tech and then suddenly
like the police don't know when to shoot
what equipment to bring how to take
these people down
who-who to put them with I like the girl
from split is back in this and it does a
really good job and at some point she's
like no you can't fight him that way he
has all these personalities they're like
yeah
we need you to go over here and they put
her with mr. glass and it's just like
and they know he's a bad guy and they're
not like you know sir hey come over here
we're gonna copy you or yeah it's like
so they do all these stupid things like
that the way they skate the way you know
mr. glass gets out again that give
anything away with this is in the
trailers but the way he gets out with
McAvoy is kind of like a free Stooges
cartoon those three stages cartoon we
only do two cartoons but yeah three
stooges short where they just wear a
very obvious disguise to get out and I'm
just like wait a minute would not I
could literally tell super far away
that's not a nurse it's one of those
things
um but yeah still the performances can
be interested but the slow pacing of it
I actually like I think because there's
such entertaining actors and it's such a
weird idea but but it takes its time
kind of going into it and discussing it
and for the most part they're discussing
it there's times where they again the
Shamel on writing it just spells it out
so much and it's like you don't need to
do that you know just let it kind of
play out particularly whenever they
start talking about comic books and how
in the comic book works and this is the
aisle and the limited to do it like
there's a scene where like you know this
character is like covered in blood and
everything the limited edition there's
blah blah blah and it's like sound silly
um but I don't know if you saw the
trailer for this and you're like oh that
looks kind of interesting um you'll
probably get it I think don't hold out
for an action film I mean like you do
get some more elements and there is some
action near the end but I mean like I
said that they're kind of building up
one thing this one climax and and they
don't really do it but the one we got I
thought was okay and the ending like I
said I think it's gonna split a lot of
people you know there's some people are
gonna like it some people like I liked
it okay so die
issues with it sure but it's like I
don't know what she'll know a movie
heaven I had issues with they're still
entertaining I mean they were so
entertaining and yeah I think it's I
can't I don't think they're planning any
more I'm not sure it's it's hard to tell
I it's the way they're running the
credits at the end cuz it says like
glass and these little shards it's like
unbreakable and split you see all these
little pictures and shards for like the
other movies it's like I think they're
building up like this is the last one um
evidence it's not a bad place to stop
you could keep going definitely but I
don't know I I don't think it's a bad
place to stop if they did make more I
mean I I guess I'd be interested like I
say it's a funky idea and I think it's
kind of an I think it's kind of a fun
idea that you know it you could even can
do a little bit more with it it's such a
you know there's so many superhero
movies out right now that try these
different styles and everything and some
some are really good and then some are
just kind of just part of the mix now
account blending together and this is
kind of distinct this is kind of its own
unique thing and and the way they
explain in the way they talked about it
and the way they act off each other I
mean it's like it is pretty unique so
I'm down if they make more movies I
don't think that's what's gonna happen I
like they're gonna stop here so it's not
that bad and ending I I think it was
enjoyable I I but keeping in mind
there's a lot of sitting around there's
a lot of talking there's a lot of it's
mostly the psych ward
that's like 2/3 of the movie is inside
that psych ward um but I love that shit
I love are they crazy are they not crazy
trying to convince them whether or not
this is going out or it isn't going on
so I like those kind of movies but maybe
you're looking for like your big Marvel
movie you're a big action film and this
really isn't what it is this is much
more
I guess psychological I mean it's like
I'm trying to think like a lot of them I
didn't learn you know what would
Willis's character again I felt like I
didn't learn much more than what I knew
before and that is kind of maybe than me
I think that's the one weak link for me
where everyone was kind of felt like
they've evolved in a way or I found out
more about them
he's the only one where I was like I
don't really know much more and then
anything of interest that was there it
was just under 12 monkeys race
questioning whether or not he actually
has these abilities and literally he
played that same part in 12 monkeys and
it was done a lot better so but it's not
it's not awful it's not like
distractingly bad it's just something
that could have been a lot stronger but
I thought it was all right I was an okay
movie um I think you can get an idea
about whether or not this is something
that you want to go see or you're gonna
enjoy and I like a lot of his movies I
feel like especially these movies be
unbreakable movies I feel like the
ending is gonna probably be polarizing
for a lot of people so we'll see I'm
curious uh what people think of this
ending you know I say that the end of
like all of hell of a break a bone split
and everything but I am curious that but
I I like that I can say that like they
here's this film series where I'm like I
don't know what people are gonna think
of the ending we're in a lot of cases
you just go wow that was amazing or odd
house crap you know like you just know
right away with this one it's like I
don't know you know it's kind of like it
is it kind of clever does it kind of I
feel works okay and kind of tying
everything into like the bigger theme of
the movies and it goes it goes this
super complicated route but that's kind
of like the comic book element to me
that's just like this this is a silly
idea it's a really silly idea and so I
kind of feel like when you take these
little leaps here and there if it's to
kind of work out a greater good I think
it's worth I think if they create an
environment where you can do that um he
even the stupid cops the more I think
about it kind of falls into a comic book
movie
so I thought it was alright I don't know
what people are gonna think of it but
but I thought was entertaining I you
know it's funny it is Shambala it's
actually turned into one of my favorite
directors to watch like even in his bad
films they are just so much fun and
they're so entertaining it they're just
that I don't know they're not really
boring it's like the most boring he did
was probably like watching my god The
Last Airbender
you know that's cuz you're basing it off
of something else but even then it was
just so entertaining Lee dumb at some
points and just the choices they make so
I don't know there's there's still
unique weird messed-up passion that's in
there that I think is a lot of fun to
watch whether it works or not and I
think this works okay so guys that's
about it check it out let me know what
you think I'm actually really curious
what people are thinking of this movie
so that's about it I should talk to you
later
take care
you